[Aplausos]
actitud final de campaña para Luis
Ignacio lulada de Silva antes de una
primera vuelta que el expediente espera
sea única
paso
estamos a un paso de la Victoria el 2 de
octubre todavía nos queda un poco de
camino por recorrer en los pocos días
que quedan debemos trabajar para ganar
el voto de todos los que aman la
democracia de aquí a la izquierda
la última encuesta del instituto ipec
muestra el candidato de izquierda al
frente con 48% de las intenciones de
Voto seguido por su principal adversario
y actual presidente de Brasil James
sonaro con el 31%. según el sondeolulu
la podría ganar la carrera en la primera
vuelta ya que cuenta con el 52% de apoyo
en este Duelo entonces lograr convencer
a Los partidarios de los otros
candidatos más pequeños podría ser
decisivo pero el candidato del partido
democrático laborista de Brasil Ciro
Gómez que siguió en las encuestas con el
6% de las intenciones de Voto re
expresiones para una alianza con Lula
tal como los llamamientos a detener su
campaña
Aunque La Poderosa maquinaria del
lulismo y el pulsorismo puede engañar La
percepción generalizada ofreciendo La
falsa idea de que solo uno pueda vencer
al otro
el otro factor imprevisible de esta
primera vuelta es el actual mandatario
ultraderechista revolucionario el lunes
amenazó de nuevo con cuestionar los
resultados afirmando que entregará las
llaves sin problema en elecciones
limpias poniendo en duda sin fundamento
la fiabilidad de las urnas electrónicas
en sistema electoral usado en las
elecciones en Brasil desde 1996
[Música]